il y a deux mois une photo a bouleversé
l'europe
la photo d'un enfant de trois ans mort
sur une plage en turquie inutile de vous
la montrer la force de cette photo c'est
d'avoir individualisé ce que nous
appelons les migrants pourtant l'exil
n'est pas un phénomène nouveau
regardez ces photos en 1979 l'europe
découvre les boat people vietnamiens et
plus récemment en avril 2015
les réfugiés syriens et erythréens la
réalité c'est que tous les réfugiés ne
viennent pas par bateau et la situation
de la mer de chine n'est pas comparable
avec celle de la méditerranée mais alors
de quoi on parle
pour bien comprendre dépasser les mythes
et les psychoses il faut s'intéresser à
la situation globale les chercheurs
considèrent qu'il ya deux types de
facteurs qui poussent un individu à se
déplacer sur la terre les facteurs
d'attraction d'ide poule qui nous attire
quelque part la famille le travail les
études le tourisme
et puis les facteurs de répulsion dit
push qui nous pousse à partir les
catastrophes naturelles la famine les
guerres les persécutions
la majorité des déplacements se font à
l'intérieur des états mais certaines
personnes traversent une frontière et
deviennent des immigrants l'onu cancer
qui lie à 200 millions d'immigrants dans
le monde aujourd'hui
parmi eux des réfugiés des personnes qui
fuient soit des conflits soient des
persécutions du fait de leur manière de
vivre ou de penser ils étaient 17
millions dans le monde en 2014
aujourd'hui on estime qu'ils sont plus
proches de 19 millions en france il ya
deux cent dix sept mille réfugiés les
personnes qui ont un titre de séjour
pour dix ans et qui bénéficient des
mêmes droits que tous les autres
citoyens sur le territoire à l'exception
du droit de vote
chaque année nous accueillons par ce
biais environ 15 mille nouvelles
personnes jeudi personne parce que
derrière les 200 millions d'immigrés de
réfugiés il ya autant de trajectoires et
visage
moi je m'en suis particulièrement rendu
compte lors de mon séjour en australie
en 2011 je veux c'est chez amnesty
international c'est là bas que j'ai
rencontré chouthi un demandeur d'asile
sri lankais jeudi c'était vraiment un
mec au top tout le temps en train de se
marrer tout le temps en train de
remonter le moral des autres ses rangs
le grand frère j'aimerais bien vous
montrer une photo mais elles étaient
elles étaient elles sont toujours
interdites dans les centres de détention
c'était vraiment devenu un pote puis
j'ai terminé mon expérience
professionnelle
je suis rentré le temps a passé j'ai eu
des nouvelles
un an après sooty s'était suicidé épuisé
par la tante d'une décision qui n'est
jamais vu c'est à ce moment là que j'ai
décidé avec mon pote nathanaël qui avait
vécu une expérience assez similaire au
maroc de lancer sing sing a c'est une
communauté de plus de 15000 personnes en
france qui permet de mettre en relation
les réfugiés et la société d'accueil
autour de passions et de projets
l'idée c'était de sortir du modèle où
les réfugiés ne rencontre que des gens
qui sont payés pour les accompagner et
où la société se fait une idée des
réfugiés qui à travers son écran télé
pour décloisonner pour déverrouiller
pour mettre en réseau
on a monté des programmes pour la
société avec les réfugiés d'abord il ya
des événements et des activités qui
peuvent être proposées par n'importe
quel membre de la communauté par exemple
inna athlètes de haut niveau
pharmacienne féministe engagée et
réfugiés russes a pu monter un programme
de sport au sein de singa parce que le
sport c'est le seul truc qui lui a
permis de se faire des amis de tenir
pendant la demande d'asile il ya aussi
des activités de tutorat pour apprendre
la langue française et les codes sociaux
culturels
c'est ce qui a permis à fodé diplômé
d'oxford chef scout et réfugiés sierra
leone et ayant grandi une bonne partie
de sa jeunesse dans les camps de
décrocher un stage puis une alternance
d'un an
il ya également de l'accompagnement de
projet professionnel ou entrepreneuriat
c'est comme ça que ce riani comptable de
formation mère poule et réfugiés sri
lankaise a pu lancer son activité de
traiteur puis l innovation comme calme
c'est à dire comme à la maison
une plateforme web qui met en relation
les réfugiés mal logés et des
particuliers calme c'est plus de 12
mille propositions d'hébergement partout
en france
en seulement deux mois c'est une preuve
s'il en fallait une que les citoyens
sont prêts à se mobiliser et qu'ils le
font dès qu'ils en ont l'occasion et
qu'on leur propose des solutions
concrètes call c'est une expérience qu'a
vécu carlos le président tsinga étudiant
en droit et réfugiés colombiens
il a pu commencer une nouvelle vie
lorsqu'il a été accueilli dans une
famille en france
sans carlos et 100 d'autres nous
n'aurions jamais pensé à calme une
solution open source c'est à dire que
tout le monde peut s'en emparer pour des
publics plus larges comme les sdf ou en
réponse rapide à des catastrophes
naturelles comme s'était récemment le
cas des inondations à nice en tout cas
nous sommes persuadés que les personnes
que nous accueillons viennent avec des
talents et des choses à offrir
nous voulons simplement nous organiser
pour qu'elles puissent les partager
car elles ont des savoirs unique comme
les souffleurs de verre syrien où elles
sont garantes de savoir-faire futur
parce qu'elle remarque des choses qui
nous manque ou qui peuvent être
améliorées
c'est notamment le cas de qui qui en
arrivant en belgique dans une petite
ville à noter que nos enfants commencent
toujours par nous répondre non il lance
alors un programme éducatif tous les
mercredis après-midi en s'appuyant sur
son expérience d'écrivain et de
psychologues les résultats sont
bluffants après quelques semaines les
enfants rentrent font la vaisselle
rangent leur chambre sans rien demander
en retour après quelques mois c'est tous
les enfants de la ville qui se retrouve
ses petits le mercredi après midi et
après quelques années ce sont des
activités similaires qui naissent dans
des villes alentours et qui permettent
d'embaucher des locaux
siga c'est ça c'est générer un rapport
d'étonnement comme il s'en fait souvent
dans les entreprises parce qu'il est
créateur d'idées d'activités et parfois
d'emplois quand on accueille bien les
talents se révèle et pour ça c'est
simple il suffit de se rencontrer et
d'ailleurs inna carlos et faudel sont là
ce soir et les amis je vous demandais de
vous lever s'il vous plaît
et plutôt que de se demander si on peut
accueillir toute la misère du monde
peut-être peut-on imaginer que chacun
d'entre nous puisse s'ouvrir à la
richesse du monde
merci